♪♪
-I'm here with Post Malone.
And he's gonna take me
to his favorite restaurant,
Olive Garden.
-Yeah, very excited.
-Now, you have no connection
to Olive Garden.
Want to put this out
before we like --
-Yeah, yeah. I have not been
monetarily compensated
by Olive Garden
to do or say anything.
-Me neither.
I've never been
to an Olive Garden ever.
Oh, dude, we're here.
-We're family.
-Yeah.
We're here, we're family!
We're here, and we're family!
Let's do this!
-We're family!
-Let's go, Olive Garden!
♪♪
-What the hell?
Thank you, sir.
-Enjoy.
-Your server should be
right with you, all right?
♪♪
-Hi, folks.
How are you?
-I'm good.
-Welcome to the Olive Garden.
-This is my first time here.
Yes, I'm a first-timer.
-First-timer.
Okay, welcome.
-I wore olive pants.
-Ooh.
-Do you have booze?
-Free wine samples.
Free.
-Free?
-Free wine samples.
-Wait, I've heard
only about breadsticks.
So I can eat free breadsticks
and free wine?
-So, you get a free wine sample
to start and breadsticks.
And the bread sticks
are phenomenal.
-Can we have the butter
with the breadsticks?
Like a [bleep] load of butter?
-Extra butter.
-It actually
says that on the menu.
-[Bleep] load of butter!
♪♪
-Hey, salute.
-Salute.
-What is that palate picking up?
-Mm.
I'm picking up some, like --
-A grape.
-Yep.
-Like, an alcohol type of thing
or, like, do you think --
-[ Laughs ]
You think it's a grape --
-Oh [bleep] it went in my nose.
-[ Laughs ]
You can't snort the wine.
-I don't know.
Maybe you can.
Can we snort the wine?
-Oh, yeah!
-Let's snort the wine.
Here we go.
♪♪
-All right.
I'm gonna show you how to do
the Olive Garden breadstick,
Post Malone-style.
-This is it.
-Just get the butter
nice and open.
Pick your stick.
You get first pick.
It's your first time here.
That's your stick.
-Wow.
-And what you're gonna
want to do is take a bite.
-Okay.
-Okay?
That's it.
Suck it up.
-Uh-huh.
-It wasn't the best thing
you've ever had,
but now take your butter knife.
Cut about
2 millimeters of butter.
Just put it on.
Cheers.
-Cheers, buddy.
This is fun.
The contrast.
It's garlicky.
-Mmm.
-It's salty.
-It's buttery.
-Mmm.
-It's hot, and it's cold.
What else do you want?
-Nothing.
-Holy moly.
And these are free?
-These are free.
[ Laughter ]
How's that?
[ Laughs ]
-It was a mistake.
♪♪
-So I have some salad
for you guys.
-Oh.
-Thank you so much.
-You're very welcome.
-Healthy, too.
-Grazie.
-I heard the salad's
good here, as well.
-Well, it's free.
It's unlimited.
-Wait. What?
What do you pay for here?
-Would you like some fresh
parmesan cheese on top?
-You know what?
I like croutons.
Can I just get
a laundry basket of croutons?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, cool!
Cool!
-While we're waiting
for the entrées.
-Wow!
Jimmy, you're the best dad ever.
♪♪
You look cool.
-Hey, do you want to know
a little secret about me?
-Yeah.
-I have a special power.
-Okay.
-I can guess if you like ketchup
or if you like mustard.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You ready for this?
You've got to look at me
in the eye, though.
You think it's easy.
Don't try to lie and try to --
you're trying to fake me out.
Look at me.
Hey, can I ask you a question?
Where did you go
on vacation last year?
-Rome.
-Oh, really?
Did you stop by to see the
ketchup at the Vatican?
-[ Laughing ]
Am I right?
-He's good.
He's good, guys.
-Yes!
-Chris, come here.
Do it to Chris.
Does he like
ketchup or mustard more?
-Wow.
This is tricky.
-Yeah, he's good.
-'Cause he can look like --
-He's a brick wall.
-I feel like my powers
are drained, but I'll try.
Chris?
-Yes, sir.
-Did you have
a good birthday last year?
You did?
-I did, yes.
-Oh.
Because what was at the party?
You had a cake
and you had probably
a hot dog with...
mustard on it?
-Oh!
He's good! Yeah!
-Get outta here!
-He's a mustard type of guy.
Everyone knows it.
-I'm exhausted!
-Everyone --
I know.
I don't blame you.
♪♪
-Are you ready
to place your order?
-We'll take two chicken
parmesans, extra crispy.
-Two chicken parm.
-That's my jam.
-Now listen.
Don't worry about penne,
'cause I know you want penne,
but it's only gluten-free.
So we'll have the rigatoni.
-So you want --
So instead of spaghetti,
rigatoni with marinara on top.
-Yes, ma'am.
-Just some clarification here.
This is unlimited?
The salad?
-Free, unlimited salad.
-Do we pay for anything?
How do you guys make money here?
♪♪
-Extra crispy chicken parms.
-Mmm.
-Ooh.
-With rigatoni and marinara.
-That's it right there?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Clapping ]
Rufio! Rufio!
Feel free to just like dip in
whenever you want.
♪♪
-Hey, yo,
It's my friend's birthday.
-Yes, we do
a complementary birthday cake.
-Complementary?
-And we sing happy birthday.
Is that okay?
-You don't pay for anything
at this place.
It's unbelievable.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday dear Post ♪
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That's how you do it.
Hey, I really did
get you something.
-You did?
-Yeah.
Back when I did "Late Night"
we would tell everybody,
"When you're here,
you're family."
-Mm-hmm.
-And so the owners
of Olive Garden --
even though I'd never been
to an Olive Garden --
they legally gave me the slogan
"When you're here,
you're family."
Because they were
getting rid of it.
They were phasing it out
and getting a new slogan.
-Really?
-So I legally own "When
you're here, you're family."
-Wow!
-And I want to transfer
everything over to you.
-Jimothy...
No, sir.
You shouldn't have done this.
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
It's done. It's done.
That's it.
-How great is that?
-Thank you, guys, so much.
-Let's get out of here
before I have to pay the bill.
-Here grab this.
Grab it.
♪♪
-Thank you again!
-Thank you!
-I want to say thank you,
Olive Garden.
Thank you, Post.
You're awesome.
-Bongiorno.
-Bongiorno!
-Thanks, Jimothy.
-You have a little wine
on your nose.
-Oh.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]